now the British Medical Association has
announced another strike for Julia
doctors in an escalation of their
dispute with the government overpaying
conditions Health leaders are warning
that up to a quarter of a million
appointments and operations could be
postponed as a result so let's hear a
little bit more about it Dr Sumi money
management
Rajan did I say your name right
apologies for that from the BMA Junior
doctors committee joins me now very good
morning to you welcome so a four day
strike announced by the BMA that's 96
hours where Junior doctors will be
walking out why do you think that's
necessary so we have been communicating
with the house secretary for over six
months now our dispute began in August
last year where we where we were asking
uh the health cycle should meet us and
negotiate with us on the concerns that
we have unfortunately he's taken a
ballot and actually 72 hours to bring
him to the table with a mandate when he
did finally meet with us this week he
didn't actually have an offer to put to
us and that's led to the breakdown in
communication and now we've had to call
for another set of strikes to bring him
back to the table to negotiate well yes
the Department of Health says that you
the BMA placed a precondition on the
talks of a 35 pay rise is that right so
the BME haven't actually put down any
preconditions we're willing to negotiate
our doors are always open uh the house
secretary asked us to uh meet with him
and set some preconditions however in
the room produced another list of
preconditions they want us to meet
before we could go ahead with the talks
unfortunately what actually broke down
the communication was the fact that he
didn't actually come to the table with
an offer we have given him our opening
offer which is 35 based on the amount of
money that we've lost since 2008. you
want 35 but you're saying that wasn't a
precondition for talks correct it wasn't
a precondition it's an opening offer
we're willing to negotiate but he didn't
have a counter offer okay well 35 Steve
Barkley has said that that's
unreasonable and that is seven times the
rise that nurses and paramedics have
agreed to is it that Junior doctors
think that they're worth that much more
than than their colleagues in the NHS so
I believe and the BMA believes that all
workers are paid it should be paid what
they're worth now that means that I
believe in Pay restoration so no worker
is worth less than they were before and
I believe that trade unions should be
fighting for their members the BMA is
asking for 35 because we have lost 26 of
our pay since 2008 it will take a 35
uplift to bring that back to Net Zero
and it's really important that we
address this concern now because we're
already nine thousand doctors down in
the UK and we're that number is only set
to increase and the workforce crisis is
only set to get worse but 35 a lot of
people watching will say that feels like
that's never going to happen I mean you
say you're open to negotiation how far
are you prepared to negotiate so this is
our opening offer and the reason it's so
high is because because we've lost so
much this is it you have to appreciate
this is in the landscape of what's
actually happening in the NHS at the
moment start for fleeing to other
countries New Zealand Australia Canada
because it's not sustainable to be a
doctor here and they're being offered
better elsewhere now we've got a 7.2
million long waiting list that the
government need to address they can't do
this without doctors and healthcare
workers and it's imperative that they
meet with us and negotiating good faith
the waiting list will get worse though
as a result of strikes weren't they
you've called four days of strikes why
have you chosen the particular dates
that you have in April so we have chosen
four days and this is an escalation of
the three dates that we did previously
in March the reason that we've escalated
is because the government refused to
negotiate with us and this is completely
within the government's right to call
off the strikes if they offer us pay
restoration now what we want them to do
is comple up a table and we're willing
to negotiate any point our doors are
open at any time to negotiate regardless
of whether strikes are on the table or
not and we want them to come counter an
offer that we've counted the offer that
we've made so that we can actually make
progress on this and come to a solution
but I'm interested to know why you've
chosen these particular dates because
they do come after a bank holiday
weekend Easter weekend a four day
weekend where there will be reduced
Junior doctor Cover then four days of
strikes followed by another weekend I
mean this is going to cause huge
disruption to patients isn't it is that
why you've chosen those dates so what
can happen during these periods of time
is that Healthcare trusts can provide
extra Staffing to both on either side of
the dates to ensure that actually
patient care is being delivered and
we've demonstrated through our 72 hours
strike action that actually Junior
doctors being withdrawn from care
doesn't cause safety issues there
weren't there wasn't a single derogation
request during those 72 hours which
shows that actually this is safe and we
are providing patients the care that
they need especially with emergency care
where expert clinicians consultants and
SAS doctors are stepping down and we're
very grateful for them for doing so to
provide patient care however 175
000 appointments and operations canceled
in the last strike which was three days
so that's that reassurance about safety
obviously important but it's not going
to be much comfort to those people who
risk having operations and appointments
canceled again in April of course and
I'm extremely sorry that it's come to
this I want the government to negotiate
with us the strikes don't have to go
ahead the government can come to the
table and negotiate with us in good
faith and we can prevent this from
happening and I know that there are
going to be thousands of patients
waiting at home waiting for knee
replacement waiting for essential
operations in pain and I really want to
apologize to them because it has they
have pushed us to this the government
have do you feel hopeful though that a
deal can be struck you've seen deals
negotiated by your colleagues in the NHS
does that give you hope that a deal can
be done with Junior doctors too a
hundred percent we are willing to
negotiate our doors are open we want to
come to a solution and the sooner we do
the better for everyone okay Dr Sumi
Mane Rajan thank you very much indeed
for coming in and talking to us from the
BMA thank you